there's something super interesting
happening in the 2020 Democratic primary
I alluded to it in the last segment
Elizabeth Warren has sort of quietly and
steadily surged into second place in the
2020 Democratic primary polling and
maybe just as interestingly is now tied
for first place in what are called the
prediction markets for the 2020
Democratic primary I'll get to that this
came up yesterday during my twitch
livestream there's another twitch
livestream happening this evening 6:30
p.m. Eastern Time I hope you'll join me
at twitch.tv slash David Pakman polls
ask people who do you support
prediction markets ask people who do you
believe will win regardless of who you
support and often those are more
accurate so first let's look at the
polling I told you months ago Elizabeth
Warren is not doing anything flashy but
she is slowly but surely gaining about
one to one and a half points per month
in polling and she's doing it not with
debate kill shot attempts or add
homonyms she's doing it with policy and
talking to voters including in read
parts of the country she put out last
week a detailed internet public option
policy she put out a detailed healthcare
policy education policy I just outlined
for you her gun safety regulation policy
and she has just continued to plug away
and pick up about a point to a point and
a half per month and she is now more
solidly entering second place as you can
see on screen if you're watching Joe
Biden is still in first place but has
dropped a bit in the last week Elizabeth
Warren is now up to 18% with Bernie
Sanders behind her at 16.8 it's still
very close some would argue within the
margin of error although when you
average polls the margin of error
calculation becomes a little different
but the trend has been Bernie steady Joe
falling off Elizabeth Warren slowly but
surely climbing now just as
interestingly Elizabeth Warren has tied
Joe Biden for first place in the
prediction markets right now if you go
to the website predicted
the money is even on Biden vs. Warren
now there are some other questions here
because some of these other numbers
don't make much sense you'll see that in
this particular prediction market andrew
yang seems a bit high given where he's
polling Tulsi Gabbard seems a bit high
given where she's polling she may not
even make the third debate Kamala Harris
is also probably too high Bernie may be
too low but Elizabeth Warren clearly has
momentum and the prediction markets are
seeing it in fact yesterday Elizabeth
Warren was ahead of Biden solely in
first place now she's back into a tie
with Biden in the prediction markets
imagine what kind of a relief it would
be to the world if we had Elizabeth
Warren or Bernie Sanders as president of
the United States I don't think right
wingers realize this or if they do they
certainly don't care even if
right-wingers are against some of the
policies of Warren and Sanders
nationalized health care single-payer
some version of it not caging kids or
whatever do they understand do you think
that the United States around the world
would be reinvigorated drastically in
terms of our reputation if Trump were to
be replaced by someone like Warren or
Sanders I know that they do all the
talking points of we will never be a
socialist country get these socialists
out of here they of course have no clue
what socialism even is I understand that
they say all of that stuff but do you
think they realize that the United
States is suffering such a reputational
deficit an alliance deficit right now I
don't know if they do and if they do
realize that I think a lot of the
trumpets think if other countries
dislike us it's probably because we're
doing great things for ourselves I mean
they participate in this bizarre
childish sort of zero-sum mentality and
one thing that's appealing about Warren
relative to Biden and Bernie and Trump
which may actually be to her advantage
if she ultimately is the nominee is that
she is quite a bit younger than Biden
and Bernie and Trump and that is an
issue that is coming up more and more
let me know what you think number one
about Elizabeth Warren's trajectory here
number two about looking at prediction
markets
or in addition to election polls let me
know what you think about Warren's age
relative to some of these other
frontrunners and Donald Trump and will
do will continue to do a follow up and
track this information make sure that
you follow the david pakman show on
instagram at david pakman show and while
you're there follow me at david pakman
updated tomatoe progress pictures i have
way more tomatoes growing in my backyard
now i think that now they're in the
several dozens the plant still don't
look great because I'm clueless but I do
have more tomatoes and you can see that
in my latest stories on my Instagram
page at David Pakman quick break right
back with more I am thrilled to tell you
that today's episode is sponsored in
part by Blink accom slash Pakman Blink
astiz a really unique service for your
phone tablet and web browser and it is
incredibly useful for people like me who
love books and learning but are busy
blinka steaks the best and most popular
non-fiction books and condenses them
into 15-minute audiobooks i'm sure that
if you're like me you have a very long
list of books that you've been meaning
to read you only have so many hours in
the day and that's why blink astiz so
amazing they take the most important
information the themes the insights from
each book and they distill it into a 15
minute audio book that you can listen to
in one sitting I've listened to a ton of
books on blankets our audience can get a
7 day free trial by going to blink accom
slash Pakman if you're watching on
YouTube I've put a link in the
description I have listened to blinka
spokes about economics about political
science about history about science so
many interesting things and after the
free trial if you like it you can
continue enjoying thousands of condensed
audiobooks for about 5 bucks a month go
to blink accom slash Pakman that's bli
nki st.com /pa k
a